an estimated 4,000 people are trapped on
a beach in southeastern Australia
desperate for rescue but surrounded by
one of about 100 wildfires raging in the
area twelve people have died since the
fires began in September including a
firefighter who was killed this week the
fires have burned more than 12 million
acres Georgia love from our partners at
Network 10 is there the state of
Victoria is fighting its worst
bush fires in years one of the hardest
hit areas is in the east of the state a
coastal town called mallacoota where
huge fires have turned day into night
the town had 120 degrees at 8:00 a.m.
the sky turning an apocalyptic red as
flames and smoke blanketed the entire
area four thousand people were forced to
flee to the water and to the beach as
flames took hold and lives dangerously
close to the town now the extent is
still not known of the damage as those
people are still stranded and unable to
return to their properties we have just
had confirmed that the Army has been
briefed and are readying personnel from
the Navy ships fixed-wing aircraft and
helicopters ready for mass evacuations
from the area for CBS this morning I'm
Georgia love in eastern Victoria
Australia
you